and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review for that is the
greatest movie I've ever seen in my life
a spoilers versus guy who's an actor in
his name is Benicio del Toro and he's
playing a guy who's an actor whose name
is Benicio del Toro whoa I just blew my
mind to this never a typical just buy
anything to blow my mind nowadays my
fingernails can blow my mind that was
seriously underwhelming so the actor has
to go home because his brother dies well
not just die murdered by some sort of
beat savage beast in everyone's
wondering contender is liver with some
fava beans and a nice candy see Durbin
see two stepbrothers fiancée and she's
like you know I'm his brother Oh once
he's bitten into what everybody's turned
into with a big bad wolf man a vampire
movie Asami Oh me one of the Jonas
Brothers madness that's eating up people
decent people but ladies captured by the
insane asylum I was captured by the
insane asylum once they smelled like
hurting
soda German is delusions they howl about
in front of a football to profile
alternate to the Walkman now are you
turning into a little man you see
there's nothing to worry about so he
kills everybody
so they call it an attack with a matrix
to chase it mr. pulp each projector also
discovered says his father killed his
mother
in fact he saw it when he was a child
how do you forget something like that
you see the actor is like I remember
seeing my mother with a razor blade like
she killed herself oh maybe it was a
giant werewolf I ripped her neck out cuz
I always get those two mixed up so the
actor goes to fight the evil father
werewolf and the girlfriend is likely to
find a cure there isn't one so that's
where we'll start fighting the animal
kills the father I tell my father once
twice or maybe that was a bag of cheetos
about to kill his girlfriend right you
totally changed the way I look at thee
or the end in the world of the story is
don't become a werewolf unless you have
insurance this is just insane whenever
there's a full moon I turn into Blair
yeah